en eeuu el kobe 19 no da tregua expertos
atribuyen el aumento en los contagios a
la animadversión a la vacunación de
algunos ciudadanos el incremento en el
número de contagio está atribuido
principalmente a la variante de alta
entiendo que hay personas decididas
adultos que decidieron no va a
personarse y no tener
para usted
pero también entiendo que la razón por
la que los niños se infectan es porque
la mayoría de ellos viven estados y
comunidades donde las tasas de
vacunación son bajas y se infectan por
adultos no vacunados eso es lo que está
sucediendo
and sociable según el 'new york times'
de las personas vacunadas sólo han
llegado al hospital un máximo del 5 por
ciento por otro lado sólo el 6% ha
fallecido
no
hemos abierto más de 5 unidades que
están dedicadas a los pacientes con ccoo
y 19 esto ha sido un gran cambio puesto
que antes atendíamos a 20 o 30 y hoy hay
más de 180 euros
[Música]
el último conteo independiente de la
universidad johns hopkins señala que la
unión americana se mantiene como la
nación más afectada con más de 36
millones de contagios y 168.000 86
muertes asociadas a la enfermedad